en el vídeo pasado vimos que si tenemos
agua solán esta se autoriza así que esta
vez
imagínate que tenemos dos moléculas ok
de agua de h2o ok y bueno voy a decir
que están en estado el líquido así que
vamos a ponerlo de una vez están en
estado líquido ok de lujo ya esto vamos
a decir que está en equilibrio y bueno
como está en equilibrio existe la
probabilidad de que un hidrógeno de
alguna de las moléculas del agua
simplemente se salga para unirse a otra
molécula del agua así que esto está en
equilibrio ok y voy a decir que está en
equilibrio justo con esta parte de aquí
me voy a tomar primero de este hidrógeno
que se salió bueno una forma de unión y
drone yo y digo unión hidrógeno porque
tiene un hidrógeno extra así que se ve
como h ok h3o ok este bueno vamos a
decir que está en estado acuoso déjame
ponerlo así acuoso ok y bueno tenemos
una carga positiva aquí y bueno esto es
bastante obvio que estamos en estado
coso porque todo esto está
en agua ok ya esto le voy a sumar un
guión negativo antes de ponerle que un
más me voy a sumar unión negativo una
unión de hidróxido am o h ok y este
tiene una carga negativa una carga
negativa y bueno también está en estado
a acuoso está en estado acuoso ok y ojo
éste tiene un ión negativo ya que esta
molécula de agua perdió su átomo de
hidrógeno o dicho otra manera su protón
porque sabemos que si te deshaces del
electrón de unión de hidrógeno lo único
que te queda es un protón ahora bien ya
habíamos aprendido bastante acerca de la
constante de equilibrio de esta reacción
y también aprendimos que las personas
realmente se preocupan por cuánto vale
la concentración de esta parte de aquí
la concentración de station hidronew
ahora quiero mencionar que esta misma
reacción también lo puedo escribir de la
siguiente manera la misma reacción de
auto ionización se puede escribir así
como h2o ok h2o esto que a su vez está
en equilibrio que a su vez está en
equilibrio
de otra manera se disocia en sí misma en
un guión de hidrógeno antes de ponerlo
así en un guión de hidrógeno o que esto
está en estado acuoso más
a esto le agregamos bueno pues am o h ok
también en estado acuoso y esto tiene
una carga negativa es decir un año de
hidróxido en una solución acuosa o un
guión negativo esto es lo mismo
estas dos pero lo escribo de esta forma
porque en realidad esta es la forma en
la que ocurre porque realmente no
tenemos estos protones de hidrógeno
estos de aquí de una forma independiente
de hecho se unen a la otra molécula del
agua justo lo que está pasando aquí y
forman un guión y drone pero bueno
podremos pensar que son los mismos
conceptos y podrás elegir cualquiera de
estas dos aunque normalmente las
personas la escriben de esta manera de
aquí pero bueno lo que realmente les
importa es la concentración la
concentración de estos aviones ok de
hydro
ok y vamos a pensar un poco en ello y
bueno otra cosa que aprendimos en el
vídeo pasado es que el agua pura a 25
grados celsius y eso es muy importante
dejar ponerlo aquí a am a 25 ok grados
celsius estamos a temperatura ambiente
bueno la concentración de los protones
de hidrógeno en estos de aquí o bueno
podemos pensarlo como los iones de
hidrógeno porque realmente son protones
pero bueno esto es igual a 10 a 10 a la
menos 7 al menos 7 molar molar y de
hecho también dijimos que por alguna
razón a los químicos no les gusta tratar
con exponentes negativos y entonces
definieron el ph déjame ponerlo así el p
h am el ph ok lo definieron como el
menos logaritmo en base 10 antes de
ponerlo con este color el menos
logaritmo en base 10 ok de esta
concentración de iones de hidrógeno de
esta concentración ok de iones de
hidrógeno ok
esto sabemos cuánto es porque podemos
sustituir esta cantidad así que si
sustituimos esto es exactamente lo mismo
que el menos logaritmo ok en base 10
bueno de 10 a 7 de un 10 al menos 7
nosotros sabemos cuánto es esto esto de
aquí es exactamente lo mismo que bueno
haciendo las cuentas es muy fácil ver
que es lo mismo que 7 que 7 esto para la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno de
agua pura a 25 grados celsius y bueno
probablemente te imagines que si la
gente se tomó la molestia de consumir
esta cosa del ph y que dicen que es el
logaritmo negativo entonces realmente
les debe de importar cuál es la
concentración de hidrógeno del agua y
esto es importante por un montón de
cosas especialmente importa en sistemas
biológicos aunque en realidad todo el
tiempo las personas se preocupan por el
ph de esto o el ph de aquello que sé yo
de hecho en el vídeo pasado hablé sobre
cosméticos con ph balanceado ya que
podría pasarle todo tipo de cosas malas
a tu piel si el ph del cosmético es
diferente
de tu piel no sé si esto es un hecho
pero creo que es la teoría que hay
detrás entonces hay cosas en este mundo
que cambia en la concentración del
hidrógeno es decir la concentración de
esto que tenemos aquí de modo que cuando
aprendimos acerca del principio de
lesión atelier dijimos que si teníamos
un poco más de hidrógeno de este lado el
equilibrio cambiaría esta concentración
aumentaría y tendríamos más
concentración de hidrógeno mientras que
en el otro lado tal vez podríamos
agregar más hidróxido y entonces
tendremos más concentración de hidróxido
y un poco menos de hidrógeno y todo lo
demás
entonces si nos importan todas estas
cosas que le pasan a esta reacción tal
vez deberíamos de ponerle un nombre y
estos nombres
ambite que me bajaron un poco la
pantalla porque lo voy a escribir aquí
estos nombres son muy importantes vamos
a empezar a hablar acerca de la idea de
ácidos y bases déjame ponerlo con este
color
ácidos ah sí 2 ok de este lado y por acá
voy a pensar en bases
y estoy muy seguro que has escuchado
estos términos antes ahora simplemente
para complicar un poco más las cosas y
más tu vida debo decirte que existen
varias definiciones de lo que es un
ácido y de lo que es una base y puede
que se vuelvan más amplias en cuanto a
lo que implican la definición que
probablemente sea la que más vas a
utilizar o al menos la definición que
siempre viene a mi cabeza cuando escucho
ácido stamping déjeme cambiar de color
es que aumenta es que aumenta ok la
concentración de hidrógeno que aumenta
la concentración de hidrógeno ok
cuando lo tenemos en agua en agua
mientras que una base lo que va a hacer
es aumentar también ok aumentar una
concentración pero va a aumentar la
concentración de hidróxido ok de
hidróxido esto tiene un signo negativo
por aquí cuando está en agua en
agua y esta es la definición que
probablemente verás el 90% de las
ocasiones especialmente en tu clase de
clínica ya esto se le llama los ácidos y
las bases de arrhenius y amp déjame
ponerlo con este color y bueno cuando yo
trato de deletrear algo nunca confíes en
ello porque casi siempre tengo errores
así que bueno no soy el mejor del
entregando cosas ni con ortografía por
lo tanto sería muy bueno a reunir 2
arrhenius sería muy bueno que todo
buscará en fin estos son los ácidos y
bases de arrhenius y deberías de chicle
meto grafía y bueno vamos a tomar un
ejemplo imagínate que tenemos algo de
ácido clorhídrico y déjame ponerlo aquí
con este color voy a pensar en ácido
clorhídrico ok ácido clorhídrico y es
más déjeme tomar este otro color para
poner aquí a esto de aquí
el olor hídrico ok ácido clorhídrico
bueno esto también lo podemos ver como
cloruro de hidrógeno también lo
podríamos llamar así pero en fin
esto está en estado acuoso ok y está en
esta reacción que tengo aquí es una
reacción que solamente va en una
dirección solamente tenemos una flecha
en la dirección porque no es una
reacción de equilibrio lo que me dice
esta flecha que tengo aquí es que esta
no es una de las reacciones débiles que
va en ambas direcciones y por lo tanto
este es un ácido fuerte y bueno esto se
hizo sea completamente en agua en unión
de hidronew anterior ponerlo así en un
guión de hidrógeno esto en una solución
acuosa en una solución acuosa y a esto
le voy a agregar ok un anión cloruro
esto lo puedo escribir así para esto
también está en estado acuoso y
simplemente flotan por allí y bueno esto
mismo lo podrías ver la siguiente manera
podrías imaginarte que si pones cloruro
de hidrógeno en agua vas a aumentar la
concentración de hidrógeno esto es muy
importante y cabe aclararlo a esta misma
reacción la puedo escribir así yo tengo
a ácido clorhídrico déjame escribirlo
justo con los mismos colores ácido
clorhídrico ok
esto está en una solución acuosa ok y si
a esto le suma un poco de agua vamos a
sumarle ok h2oh ok 2 y esto me da una
reacción am déjame ponerlo con este
mismo color una reacción que no está en
equilibrio por lo tanto es una flecha
con un solo sentido ok y esto lo que nos
va a dar es lo siguiente nos va a dar h
3 o am déjame ponerlo con este color h
ok 3 o déjame ponerlo con este color 3 o
dicho de otra manera nos donó su canción
de hidrógeno a esta molécula del agua y
por lo tanto esto va a ser positivo
ok positivo más am a esto le voy a
agregar un anillo cloruro una unión
cloruro ok en una solución acuosa en una
solución acuosa y esto tiene el signo
negativo un ión hidro año más un año un
cloruro perfecto y bueno estos ácidos se
disocian por completo y más adelante
veremos en otros vídeos algunos ácidos
que no se disocian por completo pero
estos ácidos que se hizo sean por
completo se les llaman
fuertes y déjame ponerlo con este color
esto es un ácido fuerte fuerte y esta no
es una palabra tomada al azar al menos
creo que fuerte es una palabra bastante
bien utilizada en química cuando alguien
dice que es un ácido fuerte quiere decir
que se disocia completamente en agua y
es por eso que nos da una reacción en
solo un sentido incluso puedes adivinar
lo con base en su composición química el
punto es que el ácido clorhídrico es uno
de estos ácidos fuertes y bueno también
tenemos algunos otros tenemos por
ejemplo déjame ponerlo con este color
ancho me ocurre mencionar algunos como
el pro muro de hidrógeno h ok
br ok también tenemos a por ejemplo el
yoduro de hidrógeno h
ok y bueno también tengo por ejemplo el
ácido nítrico hm3 ok
también tengo el ácido sulfúrico h2so4
ok
este es el ácido sulfúrico y finalmente
se me ocurre el ácido per clónico por
ejemplo
h ok cl 4 todos estos son ácidos fuertes
es decir cuando los pones en agua está h
está h de aquí se va a separar o de otra
manera se va a unir a otra molécula del
agua formando el hidrógeno este entorno
que tengo aquí y después esta molécula
de aquí al menos en el caso del cloro
por ejemplo este de aquí esto de aquí va
a ser un halógeno pero va a ir a formar
guiones negativos y ojo esto es muy
bueno conocerlos porque si dos veces en
un examen de química sabrás que estos se
van a disociar por completo y ahora
entonces fíjate en lo que decía reviews
sobre su definición de ácidos dice que
aumenta la concentración de hidrógeno en
el agua y es justo lo que está pasando
aquí porque obviamente cuando echas esto
en agua van a formar estos nuevos
guiones y drones
los cuales van a incrementar el valor de
la concentración del hidrógeno y es
justo por eso que son llamados ácidos y
ahora qué te parece si hablamos de la
definición de bases fuertes bajo esta
misma visión o definición de areños
la frase es algo que crea iones de
hidróxido o aniones en el agua así que
si vemos la tabla periódica y de hecho
justo la tengo por acá así que ante
cancelar un poco la pantalla bueno pues
si te das cuenta todos estos que están
en el primer periodo estos de aquí son
los metales alcalinos
déjenme ponerlos o atrapados con este
color todos estos todos estos de aquí o
que son nuestros metales alcalinos son
los metales alcalinos y estos metales
están unidos con el hidróxido por lo
tanto si pones estos metales alcalinos
en agua el hidróxido se separan así que
estos son bases fuertes así que me voy a
tomar algo de litio o tal vez algo de
sodio para que entiendas mejor este
concepto así que dejen regresar a esta
pantalla ama donde estábamos estábamos
justo como por aquí
déjame subir un poco más esta pantalla y
bueno estábamos hablando ahora acerca de
bases según la definición de reinos y me
voy a fijar en el litio por ejemplo si
tomo hidróxido de litio en una solución
acuosa y déjame escribirlo aquí déjenme
tomarme esto
me voy a tomar al litio ok pero lo voy a
ver como un hidróxido de litio por lo
tanto aquí también voy a ponerle un h ok
y esto está en estado acuoso ok esto se
va a disociar por completo y por lo
tanto ahora que pienso en esta reacción
a es una reacción que solamente tiene
una flecha hacia un sentido solamente es
una reacción que va hacia un lado no hay
equilibrio aquí y por lo tanto es una
base fuerte así que bueno que se va a
disociar lo que es va a disociar es el
litio o bueno el germen primero poner el
hidróxido antes de poner por aquí el
hidróxido ok este tiene un signo
negativo y está en estado acuoso ok un
pequeño yo negativo de hidróxido que se
va a separar y ojo aún está en agua por
está en estado acuoso más un ión de
litio así que antes de ponerlo con este
mismo color
a esto le voy a sumar un ión de litio
déjame ponerlo así litio y éste tiene
una carga positiva así que esto siempre
se va
social en agua y lo mismo pasa si tienes
un intro óxido de sodio por ejemplo en
una solución acuosa y déjame ponerlo de
una manera rápida justo aquí déjame
bajar un poco mi pantalla ok vamos a
pensar qué es lo que pasa ok justo por
aquí cuando tengo el hidróxido de
antígeno ponerlo así hidróxido de sodio
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que n
h y también va a estar en estado acuoso
y bueno esta es una reacción que también
va solamente de un lado ok y esto se va
a disociar en un hidróxido ok negativo
más un sodio ok con signo positivo
algunos cationes de sodio imagina que
cuando añades estos compuestos al agua
la concentración de hidróxido va a
aumentar así que si subo un poco la
pantalla lo que quiero que veas es la
definición que tomamos ahorita de bases
de arrhenius es como lo que hicimos en
el principio de la chet alierta donde
dijimos qué pasa si agregas algo de esto
o de esto a una reacción en equilibrio
bueno pues como lo agregamos pues date
cuenta que en este caso puedes añadir un
así
o base fuerte ahora todo lo que hemos
hecho es con respecto a la definición de
arrhenius donde un ácido aumenta la
concentración de hidrógeno o una base
aumenta la concentración de hidróxido
así es como lo vas a ver el 90% de las
veces pero hay una definición aunque es
mucho más amplia y para eso déjame bajar
un poco esta pantalla porque ahora voy a
hablar acerca de las definiciones han
justo por acá y esta definición es la
definición espero que lo esté
pronunciando bien a bronx tale ok si eso
es lo que es de una manera informal
brondsted ok
lou reed y bueno si te quieres ver muy
formal tenemos que cruzar esta o para
que sea el nombre original en fin
recuerda que mi ortografía nunca es la
mejor pero lo que quiero que veas es
cuál es su definición la definición es
la siguiente pensamos a un ácido así de
ok
como un donador de protones eso es
también padre como un donador donador ok
de protones de protones ok mientras que
voy a pensar en una base
y déjame cambiar de color justo por acá
voy a cambiar de color
justo por acá voy a pensar en una base
en una base como un aceptar de protones
eso está también bien padre un acepto
aceptar de protones
protones protones de luz ahora dado esto
veamos esta definición en el contexto de
todo lo que hemos hecho hasta ahorita
así que déjame subir otra vez un poco la
pantalla para que veamos justo todo lo
que hemos trabajado justo esto que tengo
aquí bien entonces pensemos en la
definición de browser lowry sobre qué es
un donador de protones justo aquí este
ácido clorhídrico es de aquí am si te
das cuenta que está pasando con él bueno
él está donando un protón a esta
molécula del agua te das cuenta un átomo
de hidrógeno simplemente su protón y
bueno es muy importante que recuerdes
eso porque tiene unión hidrógeno de modo
que si te deshaces de su electrón bueno
pues no tenemos neutrones es simplemente
un protón sentado en el espacio así que
este ácido clorhídrico lo que está
haciendo es donando un protón a esta
molécula del agua para hacer su molécula
de idron yo justo lo que tenemos aquí y
bueno esto se los da a una cierta
distancia pero lo importante es que este
ácido clorhídrico que fue un ácido en la
definición de
news también es un ácido bajo en la
definición browne usted logra ahora qué
va a pasar si nosotros pensamos en la
versión de base antes que bajar un poco
esta pantalla ok que pasa si nosotros
pensamos en la definición de base ok
the browns trent lowe bueno una base es
un aceptar de protones así que vamos a
fijarnos qué es lo que pasa justo aquí
si esta base tiene una buena relación
con éste y jon de hidróxido entonces el
ión de hidróxido quedo disociado y
podrás decir oye bueno está aquí y
aceptó una carga positiva este de aquí
aunque no es como si alguien le dio un
protón puedes pensar en esto como que
regaló electrones pero si lo ves como
producto final y es que tal vez esto sea
un poco rebuscado lo que quiero que veas
es el producto final observas que este
este de aquí tiene una carga positiva
estos dos tienen carga positiva cuando
todo estaba hecho así que podrías decir
que tal vez esta es una base brondsted
laurie es decir una sector de protones y
bueno porque la gente se mete en este
problema de definir una
lowry cuando todos los ácidos y bases de
reinos también parecen 0 bronze de lowry
y bueno eso es porque siempre estás
tratando con agua todo está en la
solución acuosa y para esto dibuje un
ejemplo por acá antes de bajar un poco
esta pantalla por aquí tengo un ejemplo
de una base produce el laurel la cual no
está en una solución acuosa así que
déjame aparecer la por aquí
ok perfecto y es justo esta en la que
quiero que te fijas es de aquí es el
ácido acético el cual por cierto está en
el vinagre y si a esto le sumó amoniaco
ojo el cual no debe de estar en una
solución acuosa qué pasa
bueno pues lo que va a pasar es que este
hidrógeno que tengo aquí va a ser donado
al lyon de amoniaco para formar el
amonio que es justo esto que tengo aquí
nh4 con este troje no que tengo justo
por aquí así que esto se vuelve positivo
mientras que esto se vuelve negativo y
esto es debido a que se está donando ese
protón y skynews no tenían nada que
decir sobre esto porque bueno es
solamente había trabajado con hidrógeno
y agua y bueno esto ejemplifica bastante
bien la definición de bronx
y una base pero también hay otra
definición que me gustaría ver con
ustedes la famosa definición déjenme
poner aquí la pantalla voy a dar la
definición de ácido y base de lewis así
que antes de utilizar este color y voy a
poner aquí su nombre le wish ok que era
un ácido y una base para lewis un ácido
ácido ok y una base para lewis ha sido
por acá y vamos a poner la base por acá
ok lewis por lo que se preocupaba era
por los electrones mientras que bruce
taylor y se preocupaba por los protones
lewis se va a preocupar por los
electrones así que un ácido am lo va a
definir como un un aceptar de electrones
así que déjame ponerlo aquí un aceptar
hace por ti y esta vez vamos a fijarnos
en los electrones de electrones ok
mientras que una base va a ser un
donador de electrones un donador ok
donador de él
túnez electrones ok y ahora dada esta
definición de lewis pues vamos a ver si
todo lo que hemos hecho cae en el
contexto de ácidos base de lewis así que
déjame subir un poco esta pantalla y
vamos a fijarnos un poco en lo que
estábamos hablando hace rato aquí justo
aquí en un principio yo tengo un ácido
clorhídrico ok ya este ácido clorhídrico
algo pasó que regaló este átomo o este
protón de aquí o dicho de otra manera
como que mantuvo su electrón así que era
una especie de aceptó de electrones
justo aquí y bueno es un poco confuso
esto pero no se puedes verlo como que
tomó un electrón de alguien más por eso
todavía es considerado un ácido de lewis
ok y si ahora pensamos una base de lewis
y vamos a fijarnos justo en lo que está
pasando aquí entonces que es una base
según lewis am y déjenme bajar un poco
en la pantalla para que lo veas es un
donador de electrones es justo esta
parte que tengo aquí esta parte que
tengo aquí así que si algo estuvo en
pantalla y me fijo en lo que estábamos
haciendo cuando hablábamos del hidróxido
de litio esta parte de aquí ok
vamos a ver qué es lo que está pasando
este hidróxido de litio que tengo aquí
es un donador de electrones y elton así
que si tienes esto de aquí en una base
de lewis es un donador de electrones
fíjate bien lo que está pasando este
hidróxido de litio cuando está entrando
con el agua está donando este cheque
tiene una carga negativa y por lo tanto
lo puedo ver como un donador de
electrones y bueno no me gusta del todo
verlo así pero esta es la definición
aunque dice lewis amigo personal lo que
me gusta mucho es la definición de
reviews y es la que tiene más sentido en
mi cabeza ya que bueno pues es como la
cosa más pura no estás creando hidronew
o no o estás creando hidróxido o no pero
sólo para mostrarte que la definición de
ácido y bases de lewis es la más amplia
te mostraré en este caso la reacción
ácido base de lewis la cual no se
considera una base de bronzel nouri ni
the avenues y por esto no tienen que
pasar por agua así que déjame bajar un
poco en la pantalla porque la tengo
justo por acá es lo que quiero que
veamos para finalizar el vídeo fíjate
bien en esta parte de aquí lo que
tenemos aquí es free fluoruro de bolón
y por cierto aquí me hace falta un signo
de menos es decir 9 menos de aquí ok
aquí esto tiene carga negativa pero
bueno te decía que este es un triple
oruro de boro con un año el fluoruro y
éste tiene carga negativa y tiene este
pequeño electrón de aquí este de aquí
que tiene de extra así que en esta
situación
voy a suponer que a mí déjame atraparlo
con este color que este este flúor que
tengo aquí va a ser justo este que tengo
aquí este que tengo aquí y por lo tanto
quiero que ver lo siguiente este anio
flúor este de aquí puede donar estos dos
electrones estos dos de aquí y los va a
donar justo por acá así que déjenme
ponerlos por aquí voy a tener a uno de
estos electrones y por aquí tiene al
otro de ellos justo este de aquí y bueno
qué hace con estos dos nuestros dos
electrones a este complejo de boro que
tenemos justo aquí y entonces si es un
donador de electrones que es bueno pues
regresamos la pantalla para recordar que
nos decía lewis acerca am de las de los
ácidos y de las bases ok
bueno si está donando electrones es una
base según lewis así que
vamos a bajar otra vez la pantalla para
escribir lo justo por aquí
justo por aquí lo tenemos y entonces
como éste está donando electrones este
de aquí déjame ponerlo con este color
este de aquí va a ser una base de lewis
una base ok de de lewis ok déjame
ponerlo así lewis ok mientras que éste
está aceptando un electrón y por lo
tanto este de aquí va a ser un ácido de
lewis ha sido ha sido ok de lewis ácido
de leh
louis de lujo pero en fin es bueno que
sepas todas estas definiciones que vimos
justo ahorita aunque yo creo que la más
importante y con la que tienes bastante
bien para entender todo tu curso tu
primer curso de química es con esta
definición que nos dimos en un principio
con la definición de arrhenius y con
esta definición seguramente la pasarás
muy bien porque francamente para mí es
la forma más fácil de verdad y va a ser
la que te va a importar más en la
mayoría de las regiones en donde estés
tratando con cambios en el ph del agua
por eso es lo que todos los ácidos y
bases hacen especialmente en el caso de
arenys
en fin como sea nos vemos en el próximo
video en donde verás cómo hacemos un
poco de matemáticas averiguando los
cambios de ph debido a algún ácido